i guarantee you everybody's going two
for two at the top trevor lawrence and
then zach wilson the question becomes
the other quarterbacks you have mac
jones of the 49ers at three let's fast
forward to eight and nine there's eight
there's justin fields trickling down to
the carolina panthers who gave up a
six-round pick a fourth front pick and a
second round pick to get sam darnold
haven't picked up the fifth year option
maybe they won't peter maybe justin
fields will be the next quarterback in
carolina
i think it was pretty interesting that
carolina somehow some way i mean
everybody me included reported after the
sam darnold trade that it was likely
that they were going to pick up that
option they haven't picked it up i don't
think that is a coincidence
i think clearly if they draft a
quarterback number eight sam darnold is
going to be a carolina panther for one
year
and so we'll see what happens now
why did i put justin fields there
i think there's a couple of people
in the nfl right now
who know people inside the panthers well
who have told me that they really like
justin fields now what does that mean
uh it's hard to say
because as i as we talked about earlier
all these rookie gm's one of whom is
scott fitter there's no book about who
they're gonna pick or what they like or
what they've done in the past at
particular times
so i don't know what they're going to do
but i do think that justin fields for
the deep strike capability that he is
going to show for the toughness that
that he has shown
he is the kind of guy who i think can
have a long and successful career in the
nfl
just amazing if it happens and peter i
mentioned on friday when we did pft live
if they do get the quarterback that they
may be secretly hoping for and trading
for sam darnold throws people off the
scent of the possibility that you're
looking for a quarterback you could
always flip sam darnold to somebody else
he never has to be a carolina panther
they could end up trading both darnold
and teddy bridgewater
if they get that eighth overall pick and
it dawned on me over the weekend you
know when you look at what it would cost
to trade up
versus what it costs
to go get sam darnold you've protected
yourself you bought insurance now you've
got a guy who's kind of halfway here and
if the board falls just right and you
get that guy that you would have traded
up for that's great and you gave up a
hell of a lot less to engineer that
slide because people don't peg you as a
team that's looking for a quarterback
and right now they're not widely pegged
as a team looking for a quarterback
maybe that plays to their advantage you
have trey lance at nine to the broncos
they are far more obviously interested
in a quarterback because drew locke has
been a disappointment every quarterback
they've had for the past 10 years other
than peyton manning has been a
disappointment the idea of lance to
denver is fascinating the head coach vic
fangio may not like it because it may
not help fangio keep his job but george
payton the new gm doesn't care about
that he probably wants to get his own
head coach in there anyway peter
here's the thing you know
there is no pressure
on
george payton or vic fangio to get a
quarterback this year no pressure at all
because
they have said we want to give
uh drew lock a real chance at this job
so
if they don't have an opportunity to
take one of the quarterbacks
they'll play drew lock and he's going to
have to play great
to for them to not pick a quarterback
next year but see
that is what in my opinion is tough
about the denver position here
you know i have them taking a
quarterback at number nine but there is
a decent chance
that if they sit at nine that all the
quarterbacks are going to be gone and so
they if they really want one of these
two guys
they are going to absolutely
have to consider
giving up some of that draft choice
bounty that i keep hearing from people
that george payton what he brought from
minnesota mike and you know following
the vikings so closely they have 900
draft choices every year well george
payton loves that absolutely loves it i
just can't picture him
you know
pummeling the next draft or two to move
up
wherever to seven which you wouldn't
have to kill your draft but to four
you know you get the quarterback you
really wanted so
this i think
i don't think they're going to trade up
and i think if if trey lance isn't there
at number nine they'll just sit and
they'll take bpa best player available
and and i still believe teddy
bridgewater a very viable candidate to
go to denver
unite with george payton he was ready to
be that starter in 2016 before the torn
acl and i think he would be a potential
upgrade over drew lock and at least
stabilize it give them an option
whatever the case may be so they don't
have to do it they could still get
bridgewater
devonta smith the alabama receiver the
heisman trophy winner the guy who at one
point we thought maybe would be a top
six pick maybe the dolphins would take
him i think as you do that the dolphins
would go jaylen waddle the other alabama
receiver before devonta smith you've got
smith
sliding all the way down
to bill belichick at number 15. what
what made you tie those two together
well i was going to give a receiver to
philadelphia at 12.
but then
when i saw the way the draft fell
uh that jc horn rashawn slater and
devonte smith were all available in my
draft at 12 if that exercise
materializes
thursday night at 10 o'clock eastern
time
i
i don't know what howie roseman would do
and jeff luery i don't know what they
would do but
my gut feeling is look their best corner
last year mike that they traded and they
paid traded to detroit to get and they
paid
uh in darius slay
he did not have a very good year
and la and and you know he allowed 77
completions last year that's your best
corner
and so i might argue that even though
they would really love rashawn slater
and even though they would really love a
franchise receiver
i
sit here right now and i think that
the corner is more important to them
right now and that's why i did it
which you know and then
that leads to
maybe
some team trading up
to try to grab uh
you know devonta smith ahead of the
patriots
this is where an interesting game of
chess could be made
okay because suppose the vikings who
absolutely unequivocally want to trade
down at 14.
suppose the vikings rick spielman has an
offer to move down to say 19 to
washington or or 20 to chicago let's
just say then he picks up the phone and
calls bill belichick with four minutes
left on the clock and says hey by the
way
uh
somebody i've got a very good offer and
somebody is going to come up and i think
they're coming up for devonta smith
and if you want devonta smith
i'm going to need your third round pick
and so
again i'm inventing that out of whole
cloth but i'm saying that to me
this could be a really interesting
scenario if devonte smith is available
around 13 or 14.
yeah you know and sims and i were
kicking that same idea around not that
the vikings would flip-flop with the
patriots but that someone below the
patriots if devonta smith is there after
10 could spring up into that 11 to 14
window and try to take him and peter i
really wish the chiefs hadn't traded
away pick number 31 because wouldn't
that be something if they ended up they
would do it dante smith they would
totally kill him
hardly unequivocally would do it and
that that would
you're right because remember remember
mike remember last year i reported this
after the draft
the chiefs or i actually reported in my
mock draft last year the chiefs had
interest
if henry ruggs started to fall a little
bit the chiefs had interest in jumping
up to try to grab henry ruggs which
seemed insane
but
that is how much they value speed that
is how much they value game breaking
receivers and the one thing the chiefs
won't talk about this but the one thing
they also think about is
these are slight guys in many cases
they get hurt
so they're not all going to play
full seasons and so if sammy watkins is
out well you're hoping that uh tyreek
hill is in and if tyreek hill is out
you're hoping that that machole hardman
is in so
they know
that you need
depth
at these slight very sprightly
uh
you know great great receivers who are
smaller people
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports